what the hell was
that in the wildest most irritating
debate in presidential history trump and
biden go at it
chris wallace morphs from a moderator
into a debater and we explore whether
joe biden will allow another debate at
all i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let others track what you do keep
yourself safe at expressvpn.com well
after you watch that epic bleep show
last night
maybe you had some trouble going to
sleep well you wouldn't have if you had
had a helix sleep mattress why because
helix sleep makes personalized
mattresses
just for you to comfort each and every
contour of that glorious body
helix sleep it has a quiz it takes just
two minutes to complete matches your
body type and sleep preference to the
perfect mattress
for you whether you're a side sleeper a
hot sleeper whether you like a plusher a
firm bed with helix there's no more
confusion no more compromising helix
sleep is rated the number one mattress
by gq and wired magazine
cnn for once not lying called the most
comfortable mattress they've ever slept
on just go to helixsleep.com and slash
ben
take their two minutes sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that gives you
the best sleep of your life they've got
a 10-year warranty you get to try it out
for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you
absolutely will helix is offering up to
off all mattress orders for our
listeners i rely on my helix sleep
mattress because i have small children
who wake me up at all hours of the night
so in those in between times i need to
sleep quickly and easily and comfortably
and helix sleep makes that happen for me
let them make it happen for you get up
to 200 off at helixsleep.com
that's helixsleep.com ben so
who watched that i told you
yesterday that you shouldn't bother that
i would sum it all up for you here but
you went ahead and you tried to watch it
didn't you
didn't you and now you say to yourself
well i'm 90 minutes closer to death
i got nothing whatsoever from that
that's time i'm never going to get back
those are definitely minutes i'm gonna
be lamenting on my deathbed now i
let let's be perfectly clear about this
i told you i told you i told you it was
gonna be chewbacca versus the swedish
chef and that's exactly what it was
that's exactly what it was
it was just joe biden being heard of
samurai your name is and
donald trump
that's all it was for 90 long
minutes i have seen more productive
conversations between homeless people
screaming about the aliens that live in
their hair
than i saw last night that was the least
productive presidential debate
in the history of the world i mean it
was truly an awful presidential debate
so what's the net effect pretty much
zero
right because nothing matters man
nothing
matters whatsoever now here is uh here's
a basic truth
okay joe biden performed very poorly
last night he did
joe biden said many many things last
night that are morally objectionable
that are outright false
he said things that were literally not
true over and over and over
and chris wallace did not fact-check joe
biden he was there to badger donald
trump he was there to interrupt trump
but trump himself was so busy
interrupting biden
that basically it was the justice
kavanaugh devil's triangle
of interruption and crazy towns so
nobody could get a word in edgewise
nobody knew what the hell was going on
it was the worst episode of jerry
springer in history because nobody hit
each other with a chair
that's all it was and we didn't know who
the father was when it was all over
we had no clue all we knew is that we
had just been witness
to a bleep show the likes of which i
have not seen
now you're gonna get a lot of sugar
coding from a lot of people today on all
sides of the aisle on the left they're
gonna be like oh joe biden was a
statement last night no it wasn't he was
garbage
on the right you're gonna get donald
trump really took it to him donald trump
was like a rabid badger last night
which means that he scored a couple of
points but he was so busy being the
rabid badger that all of the attention
was on the rabid badger now here is the
deal guys
in this election cycle where you believe
the race is
is where where it was two days ago is
where it currently is today so if you
think that donald trump has some
troubles
and if you look at the national polling
he does if you look at the national
polling where donald trump is down
anywhere from seven to ten points
nationally and he is down in literally
every swing state
or at the very least running even in
about half of them and down in the other
half
then last night was a blown opportunity
if you want to see trump win
he needed to come out and he needed to
allow joe biden to say
dumb things and then he needed to pick
it apart
i know a lot of people who debate i
myself debate a lot and when you debate
people
one of the things you need to do is let
them make their argument specifically so
you can debunk it
there were times when joe biden would
say things that were eminently false
just blatantly untrue
immoral there were a couple times he
said things that i thought were morally
evil
actually i mean not condemning antifa
suggesting that all of america is racist
as we'll get to and
those would have been great times for
trump to jump in and say something but
the problem was
trump was so busy jumping up and down
that none of it distinguished itself
from anything else it was just one
continuous fill spectre wall of sound
ending with a shotgun blast i mean
that's that it was
really i can't describe to you how
useless i thought
last night was for everybody involved
and guess what that's kind of what the
polls showed so cbs news instant poll
showed that 48 of viewers thought biden
won 41
thought trump won another 10 thought the
debate was a tie
okay what do those numbers look an awful
lot like oh they look exactly like the
national polling
exactly like the national polling in
other words everybody who liked trump
going in
like trump coming out everybody who
liked biden going in like biden
coming out and everybody in the middle
who's like these both people like
they're just terrible
all those people came out thinking both
people were terrible frank luntz
did a a one of these focus groups i
don't tend to put a lot of stock in the
focus group the one thing
in the lun's focus group that i did put
some stock in is that one third of the
people
who are in the focus group said they
were less likely to vote altogether
after watching it now maybe that
benefits trump right if you think that
the goal of trump is to sort of
lower the turnout for biden that it's a
turnout election if you can get people
not to show up
then it'll be a low turnout election
like last time and then presumably trump
wins then maybe that's part of the
strategy
or maybe the strategy last night was for
trump to go so hot out of the gate
that he sort of intimidated biden into
silence he was hoping that biden would
sort of
collapse under the barrage of blows i
mean i literally compared trump
yesterday to the guy didn't want to
fight in high school because he was
going to pull any weapon
at his disposal right bricks from the
side of the building a lead pipe
from underneath the plumbing supply a
knife out of his backpack like he just
didn't know what trump was going to
pull out and that's exactly right i mean
trump hit biden with the kitchen sink
last night
and biden didn't look good under the
barrage the problem is that there was no
way
for us to even gauge the blows it was
like watching a boxing match between
professionals
except that the blows are so fast you
actually can't tally the blows you can't
see which ones are hitting and which
ones
actually are not except these are not
professionals it was a clown car and
everybody was just slapping each other
with rubber hammers
okay so with all of that said let's get
into it
so let's begin with the performance of
joe biden and the reason i want to start
with the performance of biden is because
biden's the front runner
right now according to the media
according to the polls biden is the
front-runner and his performance will be
utterly ignored
and the reason that biden's performance
will be utterly ignored is because
everybody wants to focus on trump
which brings us to a larger point about
this election again
okay that larger point is pretty simple
the fact
remains that if this election is a
referendum on trump's personality he
will lose
if this referendum if this election is a
referendum on biden's policy
trump will win because biden is radical
biden is no bulwark against the radical
left
biden is not all there he was not all
there last night i know people were
saying that he stood up to the attacks
in a real serious way
yes he he didn't physically collapse he
didn't break down crying
on stage but he was not exactly with it
he was
he was all over the place he was saying
things that were patently untrue
he won't get fact checked by daniel dale
over at cnn who's almost an overt
employee of the dnc and has been for a
long time but biden said many many
things last night that were very very
bad
and chris wallace routinely bailed him
out and trump kind of bailed him out by
interrupting him so often
so let's focus in on what joe biden
actually said about policy
and what he actually did last night
because the media
will not focus in on that they'll focus
in instead on the stuff that hurts trump
namely the personality stuff
and this was again the error of trump's
strategy it brought to the fore all the
personality
quibbles that people have with trump
they're not quibbles i mean their
concerns it brought to the fore
everybody's real issues with trump
personally
as opposed to the policies because if
this were just on policy
law and order versus i won't i won't
bash antifa if this were about
the the coveted response namely try to
keep as much open as possible
keep american life going while
protecting people versus lock down
everything that's a debate
trump wins on the issues these are all
debates trump wins
but i'm not sure that anybody even saw
an issue last night
okay so let's start with with joe
biden's performance in just one second
it was really lackluster it was really
bad we'll get to that in one second
first
let's talk about the fact that everybody
needs life insurance you need life
insurance now it wouldn't help you last
night if you were
suicidal in the middle of that debate
but under all other circumstances you do
need life insurance
and good news for you you can still get
life insurance right now despite all the
insanity that's happening
in modern american life right now you
could save fifteen hundred dollars or
more a year by using policy genius to
compare life insurance policies
when you're shopping for a policy that
could last for a decade or more those
savings really start to add up
so what exactly is policy genius it's an
insurance marketplace built and backed
by a team of industry experts
here's how it works step one you head to
policygenius.com in minutes you can work
out how much coverage you need and
compare quotes from top insurers to find
your best price
step two you can apply for your lowest
price and step three the policy genius
team will handle all the paperwork and
the red tape
policy genius works for you not the
insurance company so if you hit any
speed bumps during the application
process
they'll take care of everything they
have policies that allow eligible
customers to skip that in-person medical
exam
and do it over the phone which in this
day and age is a really really great
thing so if you need life insurance head
on over to policygenius.com right now to
get started you could say 1500
or more a year by comparing quotes on
their marketplace policy genius
when it comes to insurance it's nice to
get it right okay
so a lot of the debate for joe biden was
taken up by him just insulting trump
people are focusing in on the fact that
trump insulted biden a lot yeah biden
insulted trump right back
it was basically grumpy old men with
jack lemon and walter matthau
and walter math out here trying to stab
jack lemmon with a frozen fish
here is here is joe biden telling trump
to shut up
he doesn't we're a senator i'm not going
to answer the question because he
answered that because the question
is the question is justice radical left
will you listen okay will you shut up
man so the left was cheering this will
you shut up man that he what are you
saying to trump
and it this is about 15 minutes in and
trump had not shut up
at that point so i get it i will say
however that what biden was attempting
to avoid in that particular exchange
again so much of these debates comes
down to the clips that happen afterward
what trump was trying to get across in
that exchange is that joe biden
literally refused to answer whether he
would pack the court he refused it
over and over and over again in fact
here is the lead up
to biden saying to trump that he should
shut up right this would be
clip 13. here's biden refusing to answer
on court packing
are you willing to tell the american
people tonight whether or not you will
support
either ending the filibuster or packing
the court whatever position i take in
that that'll become the issue the issue
is the american people should speak
you should go out and vote you're in
voting now
vote and let your senators know how
strong will you feel
let vote now make sure you in fact
let people know we're senators
okay so that's exactly right okay and
that ended with chris wallace bailing
out biden
bailing him out we've reached the end of
this question
chris wallace's behavior last night as
we'll see was not exactly wonderful i
think he started off with good
intentions and by about 20 minutes in
he decided that his chief goal was to
get trump to stop interrupting and so it
became
just wallace became one of the debaters
he jumped into the debate himself okay
more of joe biden going after trump on a
personal level saying he can't get a
word in with this clown no there's a lot
of this from joe biden last night
so let me ask you this mr i'm listening
testified under oath in his
administration said i did my job and i
did it very well
i want to know who they are ever well
i'll give you the list of the people who
are testing
you've already fired most of them
because they did a good job some people
don't know but here's it
with you guys wait a minute you get the
final word well it's hard to get any
word in with this clown
excuse me this hey let me just okay so
biden got very testy last night
and this was the again for people on the
left this was thrilling that he got
testy with trump
yeah i'm not sure that that's
particularly thrilling i'm not sure it
showed a great side of biden he did this
over and over and over
there's one point where after one of
these again
talk overs if you're the
transcriptionist for this particular
debate you had the worst job in america
last night but here was joe biden
you know kind of ironically saying this
was a productive segment and chris
wallace chuckling along with him
we have ended this segment we're going
to move on to the second segment
that was really a productive segment
wasn't it
keep yapping man the people understand
you keep yapping man i mean
again this is not the best of joe biden
okay then there were the actual issues
then there are the actual issues the
things that joe biden said on the issues
they were bad guys they were bad i know
that we're supposed to only focus in on
what trump said and i promise you we'll
get to what trump said
and a lot of it was not very good last
night there were some things he said
they were good there were very many that
were bad and his general tactic
which was rabid badger was not i think
well thought out but joe biden said many
bad things last night that will be
completely elided by the media and here
on this show
one of the things we try to do is bring
you all perspectives uh
at least all the information that you
need okay so the fact is that joe biden
said a lot of things that were patently
false
or wrong or damaging last night okay so
at one point joe biden was asked
specifically
about being dominated but trump said
you're gonna be dominated by your own
party
right you're gonna be run around by your
own party you do not you don't run your
own party
and biden said no no i am the democratic
party right now
he then proceeded to take every side of
every issue that he was asked about
throughout the entire debate it was
pretty incredible this is a guy who's
supposed to be the bulwark of moderation
he demonstrated
none of that last night i mean none of
that he would kind of make mush-mouthed
noises about the green new deal and then
he would immediately walk it back
he'd say oh the green new deal is great
and they'd be like no i don't believe in
the green new deal
they'd be like i'm not for defunding the
police but the police are systemically
racist i mean it was it was all over the
damn place
here was joe biden declaring that he is
the democratic party
your party wants to go socialist party
is
socialist right now i am and they're
gonna dominate you joe you know that
i am the democratic party right now the
platform of the democratic
party is what i in fact approved of
okay now here's the problem that
platform he approved of was co-written
by bernie sanders sanders has bragged
about this
and as we'll see he ain't no bulwark of
moderation
here right look here this i thought was
the worst moments of the night and
everybody ignored this
because i know that this has become part
of our traditional rhetoric now
but it is the worst part of america's
political discourse right now
this accusation that america is
systemically racist which again for
those who missed it i've been discussing
this for months
okay the term systemically racist
springs originally from stokely
carmichael
who used the term institutional racism
to describe any institution
that results in inequality between
racial groups in other words the only
way that you can tell if an institution
is racist
is the inequality of the result and any
inequality of result
renders the institution racist that
means that all institutions have to be
burned to the ground because they are
racist
right all of them have to be
fundamentally remolded because they're
racist here is joe biden
an institutionalist to the core
supposedly a man who's been in the
united states senate or in the
or in the vice presidency for 47 long
years
a servant of the system so to speak
declaring that the entire american
system
is two-tiered okay first of all it is a
lie about america a vicious lie about
america
second it is a vicious lie about
americans and third it is a damning
calumny
against the prospects of black americans
when you tell black americans they
cannot
rise under any circumstances because the
system is so rigged against them you're
telling them a lie
to tell a child that is a form of child
abuse in a free country
and yet joe biden engages in this
myth-making this ibramex candy robin
d'angelo bull crap he does it every
single
day and he gets away with it and we'll
get to chris wallace in a second because
chris wallace
not only let him get away with it he
helped promulgate this nonsense
last night but here is joe biden saying
what i thought was the worst thing of
the night that apparently nobody picks
up on
because it is just so such a part of our
rote politics
do you believe that there is a separate
but unequal
system of justice for blacks in this
country yes there is a
there's systemic injustice in this
country in education and work
and in in law enforcement and and the
way in which it's enforced
okay that is just astonishing
there is every system in this country
every system in this country is
laced through with racial injustice
every system
how is that not the chief issue i don't
understand
i mean this would have been the
opportunity for trump to jump in would
it not and say
every system in america is racist
everyone
we abolished legalized racism in the
1960s
that doesn't mean that we've abolished
all racism from the human heart because
that exists literally everywhere at
every time throughout human history
but the very basic idea that america's
institutions are rooted in racism
that the justice system today is
systemically racist it's designed to
keep down black people the economic
system is designed to keep down black
people these are talking points from the
neo-marxist left
how exactly was joe biden allowed to get
away with that where was the follow-up
question there
where why wouldn't chris wallace say
okay and your plans to fix these
systemically racist systems are two
because he doesn't have a plan it's just
to use this as a baton
that's only one of the bad things that
joe biden said last night
there were many bad things he said last
night okay and then he got away with
because everybody was so distracted by
the fact that trump was
like a woodpecker over here against the
tree nearby we'll get to that in just
one second first
let's talk about the fact that you know
sometimes you're driving around your car
and that light goes on you're like oh no
that light means i'm going to spend
hundreds or thousands of dollars well
now that i have car shield i don't worry
about that anymore car shield they offer
a wide range of protection plans that
can save you thousands for a covered
repair
that means that check engine light it's
a lot less scary when that thing pops on
you have the freedom to choose your
favorite mechanic or dealership to do
the work car shield gets the rest taken
care of
even if your car breaks down while
you're traveling the choice of a repair
shop is still up to you
on top of that there are no long-term
contracts or commitments payments are
flexible car shield plans are
customizable to your exact needs
car shield has helped over one million
drivers and that's why they're america's
number one
auto protection company i love the fact
that again
car shield is extremely user friendly
they make the magic happen
for you if god forbid something goes
wrong with your car you know it's easy
to dread car repairs with car shield
you get peace of mind get coverage today
see why car shield cars go farther
call 800 665 2157 and mention code ben
or
visit carshield.com and use codebend to
save 10 again that's car shield.com
codeben
a deductible may apply go check them out
right now car shield.com use codebend to
save at 10
or dial 800-665-2157 spouted by joe
biden last night and there was a lot of
it
so here was an amazing flip-flop on the
green new deal inside of 30 seconds
he said he is for the green new deal and
that it is actually going to save us
money
and this would be the green new deal
that cost him 90 trillion dollars he's
proposed
some bizarre sort of scaled-down version
of the green new deal but
aoc is part of his campaign and is
helping to head up
his panel on climate change he
specifically says in his own platform
that he's in favor of the green new deal
his vice presidential candidate kamala
harris was a co-sponsor in the senate
of the green new deal so you don't get
to just separate yourself off how
again where was chris wallace on this
where the f was chris wallace chris
wallace last night
was not only there to fact check what
trump was saying and badger trump
he was also there to shield joe biden
from any serious question
and trump was not really able to
prosecute the case against joe biden
because
he was too busy focusing in on sort of
the inanity surrounding joe biden as
opposed to his policies
here is joe biden flip-flopping on the
green new deal inside at 35 seconds
the green new deal will pay for itself
as we move forward we're not going to
build plants that in fact
are great polluting plants you're going
to build a brand new deal
pardon me you support no i don't support
the green new deal don't
oh well that's a big statement i support
you
i support the biden plan that i put
forward okay so the green new deal is
going to save money
but also he doesn't support the green
new deal and then chris wall says
okay what do you mean okay hold up you
just said it's gonna save money but you
don't support it why not why don't you
support the green new deal wouldn't that
be the normal follow-up question
never comes okay other moments from joe
biden last night so there's gonna be a
lot of focus
and there has been a lot of focus on
trump's words on white supremacy which
we'll get to
in just one second again an irredeemably
stupid error
by by trump last night on the stage but
joe biden also said a thing that was not
only irredeemably stupid
but also morally benighted and everybody
is just pretending it doesn't mean
anything
in fact megan kelly is trending for
pointing out that it does mean something
so
joe biden was asked specifically about
antifa and he says oh well you know
antifa
they're really not an organization
they're more of just like an idea okay
no they are called by the fbi an
ideology or a movement
an idea is something that has no
practical real world ramifications
unless it is taken down and made into an
ideology or a movement
but here is biden just pretending that
antifa doesn't exist
and what was amazing about the framing
of a lot of the law and order discussion
last night it was all about the
right-wing violence that's happening in
our majors
weird because it seems like the violence
in our major cities as trump himself
pointed out we'll see this
is coming from the left wing but here
was joe biden refusing to condem antifa
last night
antifa is an idea not an organization
you've got it
that's what he
your administration tells you the truth
is a bad idea can i tell you what i have
no
idea antifa is a danger
all right gentlemen we're now moving on
to the trump and records
they'll overthrow you when a president
i'm gonna ask a question
okay and then wallace jumped in to
protect right i mean again wallace was
really bad last night he was really bad
trump said he was debating wallace and
biden last night
at the beginning that wasn't true by the
end of the debate that was absolutely
true
hey biden defending antifa there is a
low point it is a bad move
it is it is a bad political movement it
is a bad moral move antifa is a violent
group of thugs they've been going around
many of them have criminal records
they've been burning things they've been
hijacking peaceful protests
and even members of blm will tell you
this they've been going around and
setting things on fire occupying swaths
of city areas
attacking cops and joe biden won't
condemn them because they're just an
idea not an organization
okay final clip of joe biden last night
so biden also blamed
trump for the riots in portland he
somehow came around to the bizarre
position that it was donald trump's
fault that there were riots in portland
even though again donald trump sent the
federals in and then he withdrew the
federals and the rights are still
ongoing in portland here is joe biden
saying another asinine thing
you know his own former spokesperson
said you know
riots and chaos and violence helpless
cause
that's what this is all about i don't
know who said that i do
who i think kellyanne conway i don't
think she said she said that
and so here's that but here's the point
the point is that
that's what he is keeps trying to rile
everything up
he doesn't want to calm things down
instead of going in and talking to
people and saying
let's get everybody together figure out
how to deal with this what's he do
he just pours gasoline in the fire
constantly
okay so again that is a lie by joe biden
it's not about trump pouring gasoline on
the fire in portland that is a left-wing
city
being run by left-wing radicals and the
fact is
that the violence that has been breaking
out every night in portland culminated
in an antifa member shooting somebody
who is a member of patriot prayer
so no you don't get to you don't get to
hide behind
the donald trump is a bad orange mean
man argument to avoid condemning an
actual violent terror group
in antifa which is what they are again
in just a second we'll get to president
trump's performance which likewise was
not very good
last night because this is what america
deserves you know h.l menken
said that democracy is the idea that the
people know what they want and deserve
to get it good and hard
we're getting it good and hard gang that
was that was a
a mess last night what a mess okay we're
gonna get to more of that mess
last night in just one second first let
us talk about the fact that you should
be doing
a lot of things online i mean not just
because of all the safety concerns these
days
but mainly because you're gonna save a
lot of time you're gonna save a lot of
money nowhere has this been truer than
when it comes to auto parts stores you
go to an auto parts store you can spend
a long time waiting in line and then
they have to look up the part very often
they don't have it they have to order it
online anyway then they up charge you
for the privilege of them ordering it
online
mine just go to the online to the
interwebs and do it yourself at
rockauto.com
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices
based on what the market will bear like
airlines do why would you spend up to
twice as much
for the same price rockauto.com it's a
family business they've been serving
auto parts customers online for 20
years head on over to rockauto.com to
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers
best of all prices at rockauto.com are
always reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
spend up to twice as much for the same
parts the rockauto.com catalog is unique
it's remarkably easy to navigate
you can quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle and choose
the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
you've got amazing selection reliably
low prices all the parts your car will
ever need
rockauto.com head on over to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck and
write shapiro in there how did you hear
about usbox
so they know that we sent you okay so
now to president trump's performance
it was not good okay not gonna not gonna
pretend otherwise
not gonna talk about how it was a genius
performance it was not a world-beating
performance
it was a bad performance trump came in
as chris christie said very very hot and
he never let up
it was two hours of continuous sound it
was nearly unwatchable
now if trump were in the lead this might
make sense
it might make sense because it
neutralizes the ability of joe biden to
lie at length
which would be not a bad idea right
in 2012 when paul ryan was
debating joe biden joe biden lied
fluently and paul ryan didn't fact-check
him he assumed that the moderator was
going to do that the moderators did not
in fact do that in that case and ended
badly for paul ryan so being aggressive
with biden is not a bad strategy but
there's a difference between being
aggressive
and forcing questions and prosecuting
and just
being irritating and the problem is this
there is a theory of this election it
goes something like this
the american people are exhausted this
has been an exhausting four years
we were willing to take the exhaustion
and the craziness and the tweets and the
constant chatter we were willing to take
that the american people were
up until things went bad then the
american people got in a bad mood and
now they're just exhausted whoever
exhausts them less ends up becoming
president
now that that's a war with the more
general emotion the more charismatic
candidate tends to become president
trump is obviously more charismatic than
biden biden has it he is charisma free
he's a speed bump of a human
but if the question is whether you are
exhausted last night was exhausting
15 minutes in people were reaching for
the whiskey 30 minutes in there reaching
for the xanax
45 minutes in there reaching for the
shotgun okay it was an exhausting
evening
i i wonder how many americans actually
made it through the first half hour
seriously because it was just
people yelling over each other as loud
noises
that was not a good strategy because
here's the thing about joe biden he is
doddering
he does not know what he is talking
about he makes errors on a routine basis
in fact trump was perfectly capable of
spotting about half of those hitters
right there were times when joe biden
would say things like you're going to
throw 100 million people off their
healthcare
and trump was like what the hell are you
talking about there aren't a 100 million
people with pre-existing conditions who
are going to be thrown off their
healthcare what what in the world are
you saying
right trump actually fact-checked him
from time to time the problem is
because it was in fact just this drone
into this drone of sound
if you were somebody in the middle and
those are the people that we care about
right i mean if you are on the right
you're gonna vote for trump anyway if
you're on the left you're voting for
biden anyway if you're in the middle how
do those people think of it
i cannot imagine anything other than if
you were in the middle watching this
thing
all you wanted to do was switch over to
hulu netflix or amazon
and watch anything else literally
anything else you're gonna watch that
man having sex with the octopus movie
like anything
but watch this thing and so trump came
out extremely aggressive
and again partisans will cheer in the
same way the partisans on the left chair
when joe biden tells trump to shut up
do any of these things score any points
i don't think so so here's trump being
really aggressive
saying that that biden should never use
the word smart with him
a lot more gonna die unless he gets a
lot smarter a lot quicker
mr president did you use the word smart
uh so you said you went to delaware
state but you forgot the name of your
college
you didn't go to delaware state you
graduated
either the lowest or almost the lowest
in your class don't ever use the word
smart with me
don't ever use that word oh give me your
because you know what there's nothing
smart about you joe
okay so um yeah is that funny
sure is it is it really productive
because again trump's job here is to
make
himself seem more palatable to the
american people not to see more trumpy
to the american
people okay then trump berated biden
about hunter biden
now again hunter biden is a legit
campaign issue and frankly chris wallace
should have asked
joe biden about hunter biden considering
that there are now reports that hunter
biden
was receiving money he was in fact
receiving money from the wife of the
mayor of moscow and it was in the
millions of dollars apparently or at
least firms he was connected to
trump goes after hunter and biden gets
mad about hunter
do people think this is going to make a
big difference in the actual
presidential debate or does it just look
like trump is getting so aggressive that
it's aggressive
aggression for aggression's sake
china ate your lunch joe and no wonder
your son goes in and he
takes out he takes out billions of
dollars
takes out billions of dollars to manage
he makes millions of dollars
and also while we're at it why is it
just out of curiosity
the mayor of moscow's wife gave your son
three and a half million dollars
what did he do to deserve it what did he
has not been totally discredited it was
not worthwhile for trump asked the
question then you have to sit back and
let biden lie
right so what he says there is actually
number one i'm not sure the angle of
attack is supremely
useful i mean hitting him on hunter just
to get him off his game early on i
actually recommend it but doing it like
40 minutes into the debate
and then not letting go enough to let
him lie about it and then say you're
lying i mean there are actual reports
that hunter biden has done these things
and there was there was no break there
was no backing off you need to let him
answer the question wrong
and then clock him now again trump was
prosecuting biden last night
the problem was you know in court
generally uh it is a bad tactic so
quote-unquote badger the witness
right the badge ring is not a useful
tactic
so for example i thought this was a very
good exchange for trump so trump went
after biden he said you know you keep
talking about how
you know you're pro law enforcement but
at the same time you're calling them
systemically racist you don't have any
law enforcement support this is a good
line of attack for trump a very good
line of attack what you have to do
is say name a group right he did
eventually but first
he says it 25 times and then let it sit
let it sit
now as you'll see chris wallace jumped
in to defend by this was a serious
problem throughout the evening
wallace would not let it sit either
wallace decided he was going to get
aggressive too
so there's three aggressive people
getting aggressive with each other which
is
pretty much just a wwe wrestling match
here is trump going after biden
he doesn't have any law support he has
no law enforcement that's not true
who do you have name one group that
supports you name one group that came
out and supported you
go ahead i think we have time we don't
have time to do anything
all right all right one law enforcement
group
that came back
okay so again you see wallace jump in
again biden didn't have an answer
but this is where you let it breathe
right now as a tactic this is where you
let it it's a great question it really
is
like trump has him on the ropes there
just let it breathe can you name
a group seconds of dead silence
right i mean that the prosecut again
prosecutorial trump was not bad trump
last night he was not
right it was it was the the fact that it
was constant the fact that it didn't
stop for five seconds
you need the dramatic break right you
need that you need the ear
needs the break okay now on the issues
the fact is that
on the issues trump was right and biden
was wrong we'll get to trump being right
and biden being wrong on the issues in a
second
and then we'll get of course to the
comment that everybody is talking about
today and that is trump's comments on
white supremacy again i don't know how
many times we have to go through this
routine where trump is asked
specifically about white supremacy and
then he shows himself willing to condemn
white supremacy and then he says
something dumb
and then he proceeds to and then he
proceeds to
sort of futz around with it like we'll
get to that in a second but first
let us talk about the fact that being a
gun owner it is a major responsibility
the fact is you want to protect yourself
you want to protect your family but even
if you do protect yourself and your
family
if you do it wrong you could end up in
jail i mean we've seen too many cases in
the recent past
where people protect themselves with a
gun and then all of a sudden they find
themselves
under the prospect of prosecution this
is why you need to know what you are
doing with your gun you need the proper
education
industry-leading training to ensure your
skills are sharp when faced with danger
and
you need the nation's best legal
protection should you find yourself lost
in the aftermath of a self-defense
incident
you need the uscca get started today by
texting gun to
receive the complete 87222 carry and
family defense guide for free in this
guide you will learn how to detect
attackers before they see you how to
survive a mass shooting seven firearm
drills that could save your life and
much much more it is 164 pages it comes
the bonus audio version so you can
listen whenever you want in addition
if you text today you'll be entered to
win a thousand bucks to put toward a gun
of your choice that you can use to
protect your family
text a gun that's gun to 87222 right now
again head on over text gun to 87 222
right now and get involved with the us
cca you get that special
complete concealed carry and family
defense guide for free and your answer
to 1000 bucks to put a gun of your
choice that you can use to protect
your family and your rights okay we'll
get to
more of the debate last night in just
one second including the big headline
that the media are running with today
which is trump
quote unquote refusing to condemn white
supremacy if you actually listen to the
exchange you'll see that's not actually
what's happening
but we'll get to that in a second first
if you liked our debate coverage last
night
you should join daily wire now as an
insider or all access member get 20
off with code debate so you can watch
all of our upcoming debate coverage live
at dailywire.com
apple tv or the roku app members get our
articles you have free access to all of
our live broadcasts and show library
the full three hours of the ben shapiro
show and exclusive reader's past content
available only to daily wire members if
you're considering an all-access
membership
you get to join us on all access live
every night for online and live stream
discussions
you also get not one but two leftist
tiers tumblers with your membership as
well as early and sometimes exclusive
access to new daily wire products
so watch the next debate with us get 20
off your daily wire membership with code
debate
when you sign up today you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
okay so trump's rough tactics last night
obscured the fact that on the issues he
was right
so for example he had a great line last
night and
it just it didn't land because there
were so many punches being thrown
he said about biden i've done more in 47
months than you've done in 47 years that
is 100 true that is
absolutely true joe biden is one of the
most useless politicians in the history
of washington dc
here is donald trump talking about it
let me just tell you jill i've done more
in
in 47 months i've done more than you've
done in 47 years joe
we've done things that you never even
thought about okay including fixing the
broken military that you gave me
taking care of it okay again he is not
wrong
about all of that okay and then trump
talked about lockdown on lockdown he was
totally right and biden was totally
wrong so biden was saying
that he would have saved all of the
various lives ready to save all of the
lives
also the economic crash is somehow
trump's fault even though
trump wants to reopen also he kind of
likes lockdowns
also he doesn't want to lock down so
biden was all over the place
and trump quite correctly slams biden on
this
you take a look at what's happening at
some of your democrat-run states where
they have these
tough shutdowns and i'm telling you it's
because they don't want to open it one
of them came out
last week you saw that oh we're going to
open up on november 9th why november 9th
because it's after the election
they think they're hurting us by keeping
them close
they're hurting people people know what
to do they can social distance they can
wash their hands they can wear masks
they can do whatever they want but they
got to open these states up
okay he is right about that again on the
issues i wish i wish
he'd just let it breathe because on the
issues biden is wrong
right trump went after him also on on
covet more generally
you know biden kept saying you know we
would have done amazing on covet and
trump was like no you wouldn't have
and biden tried to bring out the joker
grin and bite and trump really slammed
him
here was trump again the governor said i
did a phenomenal
job most of them said that in fact
people that
would not be necessarily on my side said
that
president trump did a phenomenal job we
did
we got the gowns we got the masks we
made the ventilators you wouldn't have
made ventilators and now we're weeks
away from a vaccine
we're doing therapeutics already fewer
people are dying when they get sick
far fewer people are dying we've done a
great job but i'll tell you joe you
could never have done the job that we
did
you don't have it in your blood you
could have never done that yet okay so
all of that
is is totally fine now the area that
people are focusing in on is this one
exchange
so chris wallace again we'll get to
wallace in a second because i think that
his moderation last night was abysmal
abysmal
but chris wallace decides to ask trump
about white supremacists
he he doesn't ask biden to condemn black
lives matter violence in the cities
which is what has been going on
they shut down the entire county of los
angeles for a week so that black lives
matter associated rioters and looters
could go and hit up melrose avenue for a
new pair of shoes
okay so so let's not pretend that what's
been going on in the major cities is not
caused by antifa and black lives matter
it is
nonetheless chris wallace decides to
pick up the democratic talking point
that actually it's a bunch of white
supremacists in the cities who are
actually causing all of this which again
is a lie it is not true
white supremacists are evil again there
is no one in america
who i i think on a personal level may
have been targeted more than i have been
or who hates white supremacists more
than i do okay i've been perfectly clear
about this
they are garbage human beings white
supremacists are not the cause of the
violence that's been happening in
america's major cities it is blm and
antifa the fact that chris wallace
thought that this was the key thing to
bring up and debate is in and of itself
idiotic
but that doesn't mean that trump handles
this right so we're going to play the
clip and then i'm going to actually read
you the transcript
of the clip and what you'll see is that
the media are just lying about what
actually happened
in this exchange so the media's lying
here is that trump is defending white
supremacy here's the actual clip
are you willing tonight to condemn white
supremacists
and militia groups and to say that
they need to stand down and not add
to the violence in a number of these
cities as we saw in kenosha
and as we've seen in portland are you
prepared to do this
do it i don't have to say i would say
almost everything i see
is from the left wing not from the right
what are you what are you doing what are
you saying
i'm willing to do anything i want to see
peace say it
do it say it do you want to call him
what do you want to call him give me
your name give me a white surprise
and write prophecy stand back and stand
by
but i'll tell you what i'll tell you
what somebody's got to do something
about antifa and the left because this
is not a right-wing problem
this is a left-handed direction this is
a left-wing
okay so the takeaway from the media here
is that he's that he is defending
white supremacists okay joe biden today
tweeted out there's no other way to put
it the president of the united states
refused to disavow white supremacists on
the debate stage
last night by the way joe biden then put
up a picture of kyle rittenhouse
the 17 year old from kenosha who shot
three people probably in self-defense by
all available evidence
there's zero evidence that kyle written
house is a white supremacist not some
zero like as in none zero zip zilch joe
biden is calling kyle rittenhouse a
white supremacist when joe biden jumps
in and he says
you know the proud boys okay the proud
boys are probably what you would call
alt light they're
they're not overtly white supremacist
the proud boys
uh the proud boys can get violent they
are not a group
that anybody should be associated with i
got a lot of problems with the proud
boys
they are not overtly white supremacist
they're not in fact the founders of the
proud boys disassociated from the proud
boys like gavin mcginnis he tried i
believe to disassociate from the proud
boys when he thought that they were
not what they were associating too
closely with white supremacists in any
case
you don't have to defend the proud boys
and the bottom line here
is that i think the problems are a bad
group okay bottom line here
is that if you actually read the
exchange that happened right there
if you read the exchange what you will
see is that trump repeatedly says sure
i'm willing to ex
to condemn white supremacists here is
the actual exchange again
wallace are you willing to condemn white
supremacists and militia groups sure
answers say they need to stand down and
not add to the violence in a number of
these cities as we saw in kenosha and as
we've seen in portland
okay so first of all in kenosha that was
not a white supremacist group
in portland patriot prayer is not a
white supremacist group
so that the basis of the question is in
and of itself false it is not a true
statement
and trump correctly says i'm prepared to
do it but i'd say almost everything i
see is from the left wing not from the
right wing and i'm willing to do
anything i want to see peace
and then wallace being a pro again we'll
get to wallace in just one second
wallace who was garbage last night
really bad he started off okay and then
he just went wild
he says then do it sir and then biden
jumps in and says yeah do it do it
and trump says what do you want to call
them give me a name and wallace has
white supremacists and right-wing
militias and biden says
proud boys and then trump says proud
boys stand back and stand by now it is
the end stand by that's killing him
right
because he says stand by which makes it
sound like i want you guys to like stand
by in case there's violence and then go
back in the cities
so people are focusing on the standby
and then he says somebody's got to do
something about antifa in the left he
didn't mean the proud boys have to do
something about antifa and the left you
can tell that from his inflection
he means that nobody in government is
doing anything about antifa and the left
and joe biden explicitly refused to
condemn antifa on the stage
on the stage that is not a clip of
donald trump defending white supremacy
you know who's actually being rational
about this of course tim scott right so
senator tim scott
the black senator from south carolina he
said
quote i think he has spoken in response
to chris wallace's comment he was asking
what chris he was asking chris what he
wanted to say
i think he misspoke i think you should
correct it if he doesn't correct it i
guess he didn't misspeak
that is the rational response but this
notion that trump won't condem white
supremacy
even in the the charlottesville
situation the problem there was not that
he wouldn't condemn white supremacy
the problem is that he was equating the
various groups at play there
but when he he he said i'm explicitly
not talking about the white supremacists
when he when he said that there were
good people on both sides right he was
talking about people
who he supposedly were marching with the
white supremacist but in favor of the
the confederate statue and i said well
that who are those people those people
don't exist
that's ridiculous you shouldn't be
saying that sort of thing but did he
condemn white supremacy he did
repeatedly that weekend
over and over and over so again this is
part of a narrative that they've been
driving for a long time
and trump is bad at this he's awkward
with language
that is not donald trump defending white
supremacy that is a media lie
again i can play the club again that
that is that is not donald trump
when he says will you condemn white
supremacists he says sure
does that sound like no to you when joe
biden was asked what he can do antifa
his answer is antifa is an idea it is
not an organization that is an explicit
refusal to condemn antifa yet only one
of those is a headline
now again if you go back to the chaos
theory of this election which is that
people are going to vote for whomever is
less chaotic
i'll say that the final note on the
evening which was donald trump talking
about widespread voter fraud
it is true that universal mail-in
balloting is a bad
idea he made a distinction between you
requesting a ballot and ballots being
sent to your house
he is right about all of that but him
attempting to sort of lengthen
the length of this election is a bad
move for him it was trump concluding
last night on voter fraud
what's happening is incredible i just
heard i read today where at least one
percent of the ballots for 2016
were invalidated they they take them we
don't like them we don't like them they
throw them out left
right they have mailman with lots of it
did you see what's going on take a look
at west virginia mailman selling the
ballots
they're being sold they're being dumped
in rivers this is a horrible thing for
our country there is no this is
not there is no this is not going to end
well
if i see tens of thousands of ballots
being manipulated
i can't go along with that and i'll tell
you what from a common
it sense you have a fraudulent election
this is such a
the problem is trump plays directly into
the myths that democrats want to push we
know that joe biden's going to contest
the election he already has
hundreds of lawyers on standby there
have been full articles written about
his various plans with moveon.org and
all of these various other groups to
take to the streets should he lose the
election
all donald trump has to say here is if
any election is independently certified
as fair and free
i will of course respect the results of
the election we should be deeply
concerned about the possibility of fraud
and we will use all law enforcement
mechanisms to ensure
that it does not occur i'm encouraging
people to go in person
because the possibility that you bought
your ballot or that your ballot is sent
in by somebody else
mailin that possibility exists so please
vote in person right i mean there's a
way to do this
the the again feeling of chaos last
night does not benefit trump it makes
this thing a referendum on trump's
personality okay
now chris wallace last night was
terrible i mean truly awful
chris wallace began and i think that he
was so taken aback by trump's
very very aggressive tactics by trump's
crowd biden strategy right got him up in
the corner and then he was throwing jabs
all night long
i think he was so put off by that and so
upset and miffed frankly i think he was
so offended by trump's tactic that he
decided he was going to jump in and
become a debater
there are multiple times when trump
asked biden a question and he would jump
in and say we're moving on to the next
topic and just save joe biden
there were multiple times when joe biden
would get stuck and wallace would kind
of feed him at the next line
there were multiple questions that he
asked that were just bad questions and
those ones are more inexcusable
even because those questions were were
prepared
in advance right so donald trump very
early on
uh felt that wallace was coming after
him i thought early on that this was not
quite fair because donald trump was in
fact talking directly over biden for
about the first 15 minutes of the debate
but trump turned to wallace and he said
i guess i'm debating you and pretty much
it did turn into that by the end of the
debate
trump was not wrong about this you
in the course of these four years have
never come up with a comprehensive plan
to replace obamacare and
just this last thursday you signed a
largely symbolic executive order to
protect people
with pre-existing conditions five days
before this debate
so my question sir is what is the trump
health care plan
well first of all i guess i'm debating
you not him but that's okay i'm not
surprised let me just tell you something
that
there's nothing symbolic okay the reason
you said that is because
wallace had jumped in to save biden in
one of these exchanges
okay wallace's questions last night were
terrible so here are some examples
here was chris wallace asking donald
trump
about banning critical race theory in
the government now critical race theory
as we have discussed is a racist
ideology
critical race theory says that every
institution in the united states is
undergirded by racial supremacy
critical race theory suggests that just
by dint of your skin you're a
beneficiary of white supremacy
and if you are not anti-racist in other
words you don't want to tear down the
entire system you are racist
critical race theory training involves
people literally telling white people
in rooms sponsored by the government
that they are racist simply because they
are white
that that's what this diversity training
bullcrap from ibermex kennedy and robins
deangelo is
chris wallace just says something
blatantly untrue in this question he
says why are you banning racial
sensitivity training mr president
he's not banning quote unquote racial
sensitivity training he's banning
critical race theory which is a
neo-marxist garbage ideology that should
not be taught on any college campus
any high school campus any government
agency or any contracting agency with
the federal government here's chris
wallace completely blowing the question
here
sensitivity training if you were a
certain person
you had no status in life it was sort of
a reversal
and if you look at the people we were
paying people hundreds of thousands of
dollars
to teach very bad ideas and frankly very
sick
ideas and and really they were teaching
people to hate our country and i'm not
going to do that i'm not going to allow
that to happen
okay so again the fact that wallace why
why what's so bad about racial
it's not racial sensitivity training it
isn't that the premise of the question
is wrong
okay and then of course he had wallace
asking trump to condemn white supremacy
he did not directly
ask joe biden to condemn antifa or black
lives matter right he didn't ask him
about any of that
we had chris wallace harassing trump
about global warming i mean it was like
six seven straight questions wait why
don't what do you believe about global
warming sir what do you believe about
he gave his answer if it had been joe
biden wallace would let it go here was
wallace harassing trump about global
warming
what do you believe about the science of
climate change
and what will you do in the next four
years to confront it
what do you believe about the science of
climate change sir
do you believe that human pollution
gas greenhouse gas emissions contributes
to the global warming
i think if you believe in the science of
climate change
why have you rolled back the obama clean
power plan which limited
carbon emissions in power plants why
have you relaxed fuel
economy standards that are going to
create
more pollution from cars well not really
okay again that is did wallace badger
biden on anything like that last night
he asked him like twice about packing
the court and then biden was like i'm
not answering it
and then you let it go yeah i think
everything was summed up by the end of
the debate
joe biden and chris wallace were
laughing together which basically sums
up
where chris wallace ended up by the end
of the debate i'm thinking he intended
to be there at the beginning this is
certainly where he ended up
the vice president answered his q his
final question
the final question is i can't remember
which of all is ranties
i'm having a little trouble myself
okay now you've just turned into a
debate participant and an ally of joe
biden
so to sum up chris wallace's performance
was terrible for moderator i mean really
really bad
two donald trump's over aggressive
performance distracted from anything
relevant that he wanted to say so he
didn't end up doing severe damage
to joe biden but and his sort of battery
on that white supremacy question
ended up damaging him maybe a little bit
i don't think it'll have any real effect
because again this has been the longtime
democratic narrative that's why that he
won't condemn white supremacy
he's literally called it evil from the
roster many many times okay and joe
biden didn't perform exactly well either
so where do we end up status quo anti
we end up exactly where we started which
is nobody gains
nobody loses the problem is for donald
trump the clock is running
if he is ahead great if he's behind time
is running out
if you're going to clock joe biden and
make a difference here you need to let
him
hang himself with his own words and
trump wouldn't allow him to do that he
just kept stepping in and crowding him
you got to let him breathe enough to
fall over
okay so the predictable reaction from
the media was exactly what you would
expect after spending years
hyperventilating over every single thing
trump says after turning
our media culture into a series of
low-level stupid debates
after hosting some of the most radical
guests saying the most radical things
they were astonished and stunned our
members of the media at how bad this was
after going after mitt romney with the
alacrity of a rabid monkey
they decided that they were going to get
very offended by what happened here
i saw a bunch of tweets last night
people like remember that time that we
all went after mitt romney for the
binders full of women ahaha wasn't that
a nicer time wasn't that a richer time
and um the answer to that is it was a
better time
but it is your fault that this happened
media you did this
you decided that mitt romney was to be
treated like the plague in 2012.
mitt romney the mildest most milk-toast
human being who has ever walked planet
earth
he is the definition of a milk-toast
human being mitt romney
mitt romney was clean as the driven snow
as anybody gets in politics and you
decided to muddy him
by suggesting that he strapped dogs to
the tops of cars forcibly cut the hair
of gay kids in 1950
and was a racist would put you all back
in chains in the words of joe biden
so you don't get to you don't get to do
this
i'm so offended by the by the tactic i'm
as i've said before donald trump is the
coroner of american politics he's not
the killer
if you didn't like what trump did last
night then you might want to take a
gander
at your own behavior media but the media
won't take a gander at it instead they
just lament how could this have ever
happened how could
george stephanopoulos say the worst
debate ever george stephanopoulos okay
george
i agree it was a quite terrible debate
i've said i think it was the worst
debate i've ever seen
also how is george stephanopoulos in a
news maker's position
in a newsman's position after after
positioning himself
at the head of the hillary clinton and
bill clinton campaign in 1992.
how how does that happen you wonder how
donald trump became president you didn't
like what you saw up there maybe it's
because
you created this monster as j cost
formerly of the weekly standard put it
dr frankenstein standing here going look
at this monster rampaging through the
cities and
you know like killing people this is
terrible you created this
you broke it you bought it here was
george stephanopoulos last night
as somebody who's watched presidential
debates for 40 years
as somebody who's moderated presidential
debates as someone who's prepared
candidates for presidential debates
as someone who's covered presidential
debates that was the worst presidential
debate i have ever seen
okay thank you george stephanopoulos
meanwhile jake tapper and dana bash
again agreeing this is the worst debate
ever
after you know extraordinarily
extraordinarily
high-pitched coverage of how trump was a
russian cat's paw for four years
it turns out that now everybody's upset
with the tenor of american politics
well i i wonder how he got here gang
it's as though
i'm highly irritated with this notion
that is very central to american
politics right now that every bad thing
began and ended with donald trump donald
trump didn't appear
and then speak words and politics came
into being donald trump is a result of
the system
a system built by the people on cable
news anyway here our cable news host
being very upset last night
that was a hot mess inside a dumpster
fire
inside a train wreck that was the worst
debate
i have ever seen in fact it wasn't even
a debate
it was a disgrace um and
it's primarily because of president
trump
one thing for sure the american people
lost
tonight because that was horrific
you just took the words out of my mouth
um you used some high-minded language
i'm just gonna
say it like it is that was a show okay
and
it was but i'm just not willing to hear
it from the members of the media who
have been pursuing
the bleep show for years and years and
years i mean jeff zucker was
having phone calls with members of the
trump campaign in 2016 advising them
so spare me the spare me of the outrage
again i'm not saying this about you know
any one of these individual reports
except for maybe stefanopolis maybe dana
bash a little bit
but it's but the the the media's
shock and awe at this debate you created
this this was all you okay so now the
media have a new narrative and the new
narrative is maybe this is the last
debate gang maybe this will never happen
again now the biden campaign has already
said that they want more of this
they've already said no no we're gonna
do more debates i i
you know maybe it's because they think
that their their guy did okay
last night and in essence he didn't lose
last night because nobody won last night
but uh heroes wolf blitzer trying to put
it out there i would not be completely
shocked if biden simply pulls out of the
rest of the debates
i wouldn't be shocked if he says that
behavior was so egregious and the media
cover for him that behavior was so
egregious that i just counted
him here is wolf blitzer making that
suggestion last night
this was the most chaotic presidential
debate i've ever seen and i suspect
most of you if not all of you have ever
seen the most chaotic presidential
debate and it will certainly
raise a lot of questions raising a lot
of questions
about the future of the presidential
debate between these two
candidates i wouldn't be surprised by
the way if this is the last
presidential debate between the
president of the united states and the
former vice president of the united
states but we shall see
i mean how badly do the media want joe
biden to win they were they were making
this argument a while ago right nancy
pelosi was saying maybe there won't be
any debates because they figured that
biden was winning so hide biden in the
basement that's their strategy and they
hope to continue that
going forward because they still don't
want to answer any serious questions
remember
in this debate joe biden refused to give
them antifa called all of america's
systems racist
and then refused to answer whether he
would stack the supreme court and that's
the debate he supposedly won
okay that is that's not a good showing
by joe biden it's just that
again donald trump's tactics were so
distracting that it was very difficult
for people
to actually fully grasp what the hell
was going on okay we'll be back here a
little bit later today with two
additional hours of content
more recap an insane story uh apparently
there is now a a we're doing full-on
malice struggle sessions
by professors at ohio state university
who have suggested they like sports
apparently you're not allowed to say
that you like sports anymore
that's racist we'll get to that a little
bit later on in the day otherwise we'll
see you here tomorrow i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
mix by mike caromina hair and makeup is
by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
you know the matt wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about
i hope you'll give it a listen
you